we focus on on the hippocampus and in
particular on ca1 pyramidal neurons
which provide the major output of the
hippocampus and ca1 pyramidal neurons
are really extraordinary cells they
receive about 30,000 excitatory synaptic
inputs from different brain regions they
have several thousand inhibitory
synaptic inputs and their job basically
is to integrate all this information
make a decision and then generate an
output and so our lab has been really
interested in trying to understand how
the information from different brain
regions converges on ca1 and what is the
nature mark of the computation that it
might be playing with all of this
information and I'm sure as many of you
know the major input pathway to the
hippocampus and to ca1 comes from an
torrential cortex and there are two
major routes of information flow one is
an indirect pathway where layer two
stellate cells excite dentate gyrus
granule cells which excite ca3 pyramidal
cells which then send their axons to
make excitatory synapses on the proximal
dendrites near the soma of the ca1
pyramidal cell to fire action potentials
and this is called the tri synaptic path
and these axons are the Schaffer
collateral axons from the ca3 neurons
and then ca1 sends output to a number of
brain regions a lot of it goes back to
enter inal cortex forming this cortical
hippocampal loop and somehow this as I'm
sure you all know is critical for the
formation of declarative memory or
memory of people places events and
things and there's been a lot of work
over the past of 30 or 40 years on the
mechanisms the cellular mechanism memory
storage really focusing on the ability
of activity in each of these three
synaptic pathways high frequency
stimulation activity to lead to
long-lasting enhancements in synaptic
transmission giving us long term
potentiation or long lasting decreases
in synaptic transmission
giving us long term depression however
in addition to this indirect but
powerful synaptic input to ca one CA one
also receives a direct input from
entering old cortex from layer 3
pyramidal neurons and these target the
very distal dendrites of CA one and they
provide a very weak excitation of the CA
one soma in contrast to the Schaffer
collaterals which provide very strong
excitation and that weak excitation is
largely due to their underprivileged
status of happiness synapse on the very
distal dendrites and so their PSPs are
subject to a great deal of attenuation
as they propagate to the soma and as
you've heard from others that this basic
excitatory circuit is also under the
influence of a large number of
inhibitory neurons there's a diverse
population of inhibitory neurons in the
hippocampus at least 20 different types
of inhibitory neurons have been
identified that can be classified
according to their molecular markers
according to their morphology and in
this example just showing you according
to the location of their axons and the
regions of the ca1 pyramidal neuron that
they target so we have a class of basket
cells that target the soma and provide
very strong inhibitory control on the
output of C a1 and we also have a class
of inter neurons that target the
dendrites and so influence the ability
of certain classes of synaptic input
burn perhaps not others to excite the C
a1 neuron so we have this remarkable
convergence of both macro excitatory
circuits coming from different brain
regions as well as local micro
inhibitory circuits all controlling the
ability of C a1 to generate action
potentials now a number of years ago
when Josh Dudman was in the lab he
became very curious as to why have both
a direct input from internal cortex as
well as this in direct input converging
on the same neuron again this is a very
direct input is very we
the indirect input is very strong and
when we you record from the Selma and
stimulate the direct input you only
produce an epsp that's a millivolt or
two so it's not able to generate
generate an action potential output so
Josh reason that well rather than having
these inputs act as direct excitatory
drives of ca1 output
maybe they can serve as instructive
signals by interacting with the Schaffer
collateral inputs to lead to some
regulation of the efficacy of excitation
through this excitatory Schaefer
collateral pave and indeed Josh found
when he paired stimulation of the
internal cortex with the Schaffer
collateral inputs and this was all done
in isolated hippocampal slice at a low
frequency for about a minute or a minute
and a half he was able to produce a very
strong potentiation of the excitation by
the Schaffer collateral pathway and Josh
turned this form of plasticity I TVV I
TDP or input timing-dependent plasticity
by analogy with spike timing-dependent
plasticity and so in the years since
Josh did his initial experiments joi de
Basu then joined the lab and decided to
look in more detail about the circuits
that was able to implement some of the
very interesting features of AI TDP and
so I just want to summarize today some
of the roles that the circuits that
she's identified within the hippocampus
she's found that one class of inhibitory
neurons the basket cells play a clinic a
critical role in the expression of IT VP
by regulating AI TDP regulates the
strength of this feed-forward inhibition
and then she identified a second set of
inter neurons these dendrite are getting
into neurons that normally control the
induction of AI TDP by receiving
powerful by promoting powerful
feed-forward inhibition of the dendrites
they normally prevent the Schaffer
collateral pathway from inducing itvbe
and finally a third player is someone
unexpectedly involves a long range
input from inhibitory neurons from
internal cortex that had been
underappreciated and these inhibitory
interneurons selectively target these
dendrite targeting inter neurons and so
when we activate the internal cortex
inputs we transiently inhibit this
feed-forward inhibition and this leads
to a dis inhibitory relief of the
circuit and enables us to induce ITBP so
that's just the general overview of what
I want to tell you about some of the
specific experiments that Joey de and
Josh have done over the past several
years to work out the circuitry and so
to provide us with an example of how one
can build inherent inherent within the
synaptic connectivity of the hippocampus
we have these local synaptic learning
rules embedded within the circuitry so
it's not all hebbian plasticity we think
but there are also within the complex
circuitry very specific mechanisms for
controlling the activity of this
particular circuit and as we will see
contributing to memory storage so to
look at the properties of I TDP as I
mentioned what Josh did was he obtained
a hippocampal slice and he stimulated
separately the Schaffer collateral
inputs as well as the entire neural
cortex inputs with two stimulating
electrodes and recorded the response
within the cell body and he measured the
effect of pairing the internal cortex in
the Schaffer collateral inputs for about
90 seconds at 1 Hertz and he looked at
the ability of that to influence both
the Schaffer collateral epsp or synaptic
potential as well as the internal cortex
synaptic potential and he did all of
this with inhibition intact and what
Josh found somewhat surprisingly was
that he was able to produce a very large
long-lasting potentiation of the
Schaffer collateral input but not no
effect on the internal cortex input by
this pairing of these two pathways and
moreover he found that the potential
which could be somewhere between two and
a half to three fold of this
depolarization or the excitation of the
ca1 pyramidal neuron was finely tuned to
the pairing interval and was maximal
when the antirattle cortex input was
stimulated exactly 20 milliseconds
before the Schaefer collateral input so
he had to stimulate the enter on the
cortex input first 20 milliseconds later
he stimulated the Schaefer collateral
input and he repeated that pairing at 1
Hertz for 60 to 90 seconds stop the
pairing and then just stimulated the
Schaefer collateral pathway alone and
saw this very pronounced potentiation of
the ability of the Schaefer collateral
input to depolarize the ca1 pyramidal
neuron and as I said this is very finely
tuned to this pairing interval he saw
very little potentiation at a 30
millisecond interval a 10 millisecond
interval when he reversed the pairing
there was no significant potentiation
and this potentiation had a number of
similarity similar properties and
differences with regular old LTP unlike
LTP it was a hetero synaptic learning
mechanism the entorhinal cortex would
provided a teaching role in stimulating
the inducing plasticity at the Schaefer
collateral inputs it was produced by low
frequency weak sub-threshold parents of
the ca1 pyramidal neurons never fired an
action potential however it also
required activation of NMDA receptors it
required calcium influx into the ca1
pyramidal neuron and the activation of M
blue our receptors so we have this
convergent activation of these two
different pathways leading to this
pronounced potentiation and perhaps one
of the interesting features is that this
represents a non heavy and learning rule
because we are we rewarding the Schaffer
collateral inputs where potentiating the
synaptic effect of these inputs not for
a generate for predicting of action
potential firing in the ca1 pyramidal
but rather for being activated at the
precise interval after the ca1 pyramidal
neuron is depolarized by its internal
cortex inputs and was particularly
interesting about this 20 millisecond
interval is that it matches the
predicted delay line architecture of the
hippocampus because the Tri synaptic
pathway in firm ation arriving from
arising from the internal cortex has
been shown to take about 20 milliseconds
longer to propagate through the tri
synaptic path than the direct path and
it's of interest and perhaps coincidence
or perhaps not that this I TDP is
induced precisely at this interval that
we think matches the built-in delay line
architecture of the hippocampus so we
think this is an interesting synaptic
learning rule in addition to more
typical hebbian forms of synaptic
plasticity and the plasma at the end of
josh's experiments there are really two
open questions one is what is the nature
of the synaptic changes that underlie
the expression of AI TDP how can this
very weak pairing of this pre in this
postsynaptic cell produce such a large
two-and-a-half to three fold
potentiation which is often larger than
the LTP you get with very strong Titanic
stimulation of the Schaffer collateral
input and then the second question was
what controls the precise timing
dependence of AI TDP how is it tuned so
exactly to this 20 millisecond interval
in both cases what I will tell you is
that inhibition plays a key role in in
both of these properties so one the
first question that we approached was
what is the nature of the mechanism
leading to the expression of AI TDP now
because the Shafer collateral input both
directly excites the ca1 pyramidal
neuron but also excites these inhibitory
basket cells the net PSP that one
measures is a sum of excitation and
inhibition overlapping excitation and
inhibition so the enhancement of the PSP
after we induce AI TDP so this is an
sample experiment that Jowita did just
showing the size of the Schaefer
collateral evoke PSP again with
inhibition intact before and after I TDP
the potentiation in principal could be
do either to the suppression of
feed-forward inhibition and or the
potentiation of excitation or a
combination of the two so to get out
that question what your ADA did was
dissected out the amount of pure
excitation form inhibition by blocking
gaba receptors gaba
a and gaba B receptors and measuring the
size of the pure epsp prior to the
induction of I TDP and by subtracting
the pure epsp from the net postsynaptic
potential which is the sum of the epsp
and the IPS B the inhibitory response
joie de could derive the inferred size
of the IPS P so you can see that when we
stimulate the Schaffer collateral
pathway there's a large epsp that sums
with a large IPSP to generate a net
depolarizing synaptic response now when
she applied the gaba blockers after she
induced i TDP surprisingly the gaba
blockers had relatively little effect
and if she compared the pure epsp in the
presence of gaba blockers before and
after the induction of i TDP you can see
there was about a forty percent
enhancement in the size of the pure
excitatory response and so that what
this tells us is that one component of i
TDP is due to the long-term potentiation
of excitatory synaptic transmission or e
LTP however when she now measured the
inferred ipsp what you could see is
after the induction of AI TDP there's a
large reduction in the size of the
inhibitory postsynaptic potential and so
the net effect this large enhancement
that we see in the postsynaptic
potential is due to these synergistic
effects of enhancing excitation and
depressing inhibition enjoy a dominant
issue identify the population of inter
neurons that were being regulated
they were a cholecystokinin expressing
class of basket cells that act in
parallel to the parvalbumin positive
basket cells that Lindsay mentioned and
what we see is that there this effect is
mediated the suppression of its effect
is mediated by the release of ended
cannabinoids from the pyramidal neuron
that activates the cb1 type and a
cannabinoid receptor which is known to
suppress gaba release so this we think
is a the mechanism underlying the
expression of I TDP so then this leaves
the second question is what controls the
precise timing dependence of iddp why is
it so tightly tuned to that 20
millisecond interval so one clue to this
came from an experiment that Jowita did
this was a tuning curve the typical
tuning curve that she obtained with
inhibition intact and then she asked
does this precise timing depend on
inhibitory neurons because in many cases
we know that it one of the roles of
inhibition is to finally control the
timing dependence of excitation so
Jowita repeated the I TDP induction
protocol but now she blocked all
inhibitory synaptic transmission only
during the period of pairing the
presynaptic and postsynaptic cell and
what she found was that when inhibition
was blocked only during this induction
phase she could still induce a very nice
I TDP if anything it was a little larger
we got a three-fold potentiation but now
this very precise timing dependence was
lost 30 millisecond 10 millisecond delay
produced about the same amount of
potentiation as we saw with the 20
millisecond delay so this very tight
tuning curve clearly depended on
inhibition so how can we explain the the
effective inhibition to tighten up the
timing dependence of I TDP so in order
to try and explore this question what
Jowita did was she performed experiments
where she instead of recording from the
soma
she decided to record from the dendrite
of the ca1 pyramidal neuron the site of
presume
integration of the epsp from the
internal cortex in the shape or
collateral and perhaps the site at which
an inhibitory neuron could exert its
influence and what she found was that
when she stimulated the antirattle
cortex input alone and recorded from the
dendrite she in this case in this
particular cell there was only a very
small net depolarizing response even
when she recorded from the dendrite when
she recorded from the Schaefer
collateral pathway alone when she
stimulated the Schaefer collateral she
recorded a nice large epsp in the
dendrite and now when she paired the two
of them together well first of all if
they were just some mating linearly
because the epsp induced by the internal
cortex was so small linear summation
would just give a very small boosting
but when she actually activated the
Schaffer collaterals 20 milliseconds
after stimulating the internal cortex
she saw there was about a 40% boosting
in the size of the net synaptic
depolarization when she paired the two
so this was telling us that there was
some superlinear interaction going on
when she stimulated these two pathways
together she then went on to show that
this superlinear effect depended on
exactly was maximal at this 20
millisecond interval when she paired the
internal cortex with the Schaefer
collateral stimulation at the other
intervals the sum the epsp was much less
than it was with the 20 millisecond
pairing and mostly it was either linear
or super linear sublinear the the
summation now when she blocked
inhibition interestingly well first of
all the epsps got larger because now the
underlying feed forward inhibition is
gone but when she looked at the effect
of pairing the internal cortical
stimulation with the Schaefer collateral
stimulation and compared the predictions
of a linear sum of the epsp now you can
see the epsp to the Schaefer collateral
down here I'm sorry to the internal
cortex this is the animal cortex epsp on
top of that writing on top of that is
the Schaefer collaterally PSP now the
aired activation produced only linear or
sub linear summation we no longer got
that super linear boosting when
inhibition was blocked and moreover the
peak response now occurred at 10
milliseconds rather than 20 milliseconds
and actually that 10 milliseconds is
what one would predict just by the
summation the passive summation of the
internal cortex the PSP and the shape or
collateral epsp so somehow inhibition is
doing something special even though
inhibition is suppressing the epsp
somehow inhibition was required for this
super linear summation so how can we
explain that how can we explain that
having inhibition there gives us more
summation than we would predict and
there's actually a fairly simple model
of which I mentioned at the beginning of
the talk this idea that the Schaefer
color that there is a disinhibitory
effect on feed-forward inhibition when
we stimulate the anti-rattle cortex
pathway so the idea is that there is a
class of inter neuron so it's a
well-known class of inter neurons that
sit at the border of stratum radiata
mand stratum lock and osa molecular
right out at the the border where the
anti-rattle cortex inputs come in and
where the Schaefer collateral inputs end
and these inter neurons are known to
receive strong excitation by the
Schaefer collateral inputs and they're
also excited by the internal cortex
inputs so what we imagine is that every
time we stimulate the Schaefer
collateral inputs and record from the
ca1 pyramidal neuron there is a mixed
epsp in the dendrites as well as an IPS
P in the dendritic ipsp due to this
class of stratum ratty items stratum
locking us and molecular RA into neurons
and so the net depolarization is much
less than the pure EPS
because of this opposing inhibition and
all of this is going out in the is
happening out in the dendrites and
independent from the other class of
basket cells that were innovating the
soma so we predict that there is a large
feed-forward inhibition
that's limiting the ability of the
Schaffer collaterals to activate the
dendrites now we imagine that there are
these long-range inhibitory projections
which have been identified by Hana
Monet's lab that come enter the
hippocampus from the internal cortex and
they're known to selectively target
inter neurons out at this boundary zone
and so what we presume is that when we
stimulate the internal cortex pathway we
activate both the excitatory inputs that
generate an epsp in the pyramidal neuron
may help to excite this inter neuron but
at the same time we activate these
long-range inhibitory projections and we
induce an IPS P in these inter neurons
so if we were to just first stimulate
the internal cortex pathway and then
stimulate the Schaffer collaterals soon
after if the inter neurons are inhibited
by these long-range projections then
this ability of the Schaffer collaterals
to activate these inter neurons will be
reduced and the IPS P that these inter
neurons produce in the ca1 pyramidal
neuron will be decreased and as a result
the net depolarization will be increased
and so what this is what we think
underlies the super linear summation
between the activation of the Perret of
the internal cortex pathway and the
Schaffer collateral that way it's not
that anything that's happening within
the pyramidal neuron itself it's not
that we're firing a dendritic spike but
rather it's simply that they we are
inhibiting this local class of
inhibitory interneurons and so we are
revealing a larger epsp a larger
depolarizing response so that's the
model and how can we test that
well what Jowita did
was to perform patch-clamp recordings
from this class of interneurons and then
to stimulate the internal cortex inputs
and the shaper collateral input and to
measure the synaptic response and we see
when she stimulated the shape for
collateral inputs and recorded from
these inter neurons she saw there was a
large epsp that often was able to fire
an action potential in these inter
neurons now when she stimulated the
internal cortex inputs she saw something
interesting she saw that there was an
initial epsp which was rapidly followed
by a large ipsp and the peak of the IPSP
occurred 20 milliseconds after the start
of the stimulation so the this inter
neuron in fact was indeed being
maximally inhibited just at the time at
which the Schaefer collateral response
was being boosted by the stimulation of
the internal cortex inputs so finally
this IPSP is possibly due to these
long-range inhibitory projections but it
also could be that these pyramidal
neuron axons coming from the internal
cortex were exciting another class of
inter neurons that selectively targeted
inter neurons so these are the two
possible explanations for this ipsp that
we record in the inter neuron and to
distinguish between them what your ADA
did was she applied blockers of
glutamate receptors to block the ability
of the entorhinal cortex inputs to
excite a local inter neuron but this
should leave direct inhibition intact
and in fact when joy you have blocked
all excitation and stimulated the
internal cortex inputs
she still she was able to block the epsp
in these inter neurons and reveal intact
this large IPS P so indeed whenever we
stimulate put our stimulating out
electrode out in the distal dendrites we
are both producing an IP an epsp in the
pyramidal neuron but perhaps even more
importantly we're producing a pow
I PSP in this class of dendrite
targeting interneurons and thereby
suppressing the ability of the shape for
collateral inputs to activate these in
these inter neurons so the next question
that Jowita asked was well are the is
this inhibition really coming from these
long-range inhibitory projections from
enter a neural cortex so to get at that
question what she did was to express
channelrhodopsin in the internal cortex
in a GAD to crea line of mice that
expressed query Kombat a selectively in
inter neurons and she used a Cree
dependent virus to only express
channelrhodopsin in inter neurons in the
inventory neurons in the internal cortex
and then she obtained a hippocampal
slice and used light to activate the
channelrhodopsin in the any inhibitory
projections that might be coming to
hippocampus and what she found was that
when she expressed channelrhodopsin in
media either medial internal cortex
which provides mostly spatial
information to hippocampus or lateral
internal cortex which provides non
spatial information and recorded the
inhibitory postsynaptic current under
voltage clamp and that's these inter
neurons these border inter neurons she
saw that indeed the activation of these
long-range projections was able to
induce a very large inhibitory outward
current that was blocked by blockers of
GABA a and gaba B receptors but was
unaffected by blockers of excitatory
transmission so in fact this was a
direct and inventory projection coming
from the internal cortex and
predominantly it was lateral internal
cortex that was it inducing the largest
inhibitory response although medial
internal cortex also send projections
into the hippocampus so this then led us
to ask well what is the functional role
of these inhibitory inputs in that
synaptic boosting that we saw when we
paired the perforin path activation with
the shape or collateral activation
so do these long-range projections
really mediate that's superlinear
summation because remember according to
our model whenever we stimulate the
internal cortex pathway with our
electrical stimulation the major effect
that we think we're doing to boost the
signal is to transiently inhibit this
population of interneurons so to test
that idea
Joetta expressed a pharmacogenetic agent
this that was developed by Scott Stearns
an engineer farm he calls this as PCM
glycine receptor it's an engineered
glycine receptor that is activated by a
cognate ligand called PCM selectively
and so she expressed this piece on
glycine receptor in inhibitory neurons
in a neuronal cortex and then gave
paired stimulation of the n-terminal
cortex in Schaffer collateral inputs
just as before and you can see again she
saw this super linear summation peaked
at the 20 millisecond interval and now
when she inactivated when she silenced
these inputs with this whoops with the
piece an Ligon she completely blocked
this super linear summation and now the
Schaffer collateral and enteral cortex
pathways just showed normal linear or
sub linear summation so indeed
suggesting that these that this
disinhibition model was correct
so finally Jowita looked at i TVP itself
and said do we really need these inputs
to induce this i TDP when we pair the
n-terminal cortex and Schaffer
collateral inputs and this is just the
normal time course of ITBP that one
typically sees when we pair the enteral
cortex and Schaffer collateral inputs
this potentially fold two and a half to
three full potentiation lasting 40
minutes and when she silenced these
inputs these long-range inhibitory
inputs she completely blocked the
ability to induce I TDP presumably
because these inter neurons now were no
longer being suppressed by these
anti-riot in here
Torian puts for mental cortex so we were
getting a constitutive inhibition of the
dendrites every time we stimulated the
Schaffer collateral inputs so so far
we've been looking at the role of these
inputs in isolated slices and the
question then is what is its
physiological relevance under what
conditions might these inputs be
activated under in vivo conditions and
so here Jowita teamed up with Jeff
Zaremba and Ottilia lasso cheese lab and
the two of them decided to express gee
camp six in the inhibitory neurons and
n-terminal cortex and then use in vivo
two-photon microscopy to image the axons
of these inhibitory projections from
entering our cortex in the ca1 region of
the hippocampus and what what this the
set up that they used was a mouse that
was running on a on a treadmill with
various textures and they were able to
apply various sensory stimuli and
noxious air puffs to the eye of the
mouse a water reward tone or light or in
various combinations and this is just an
example of what one of these axon
inhibitory projections looks like in the
two-photon microscope and just as
Lindsay had described we had image
Jowita and Jeff had image activity in
individual blue tones along one axon or
along multiple accidents and this is
just an example of a calcium response to
a to an air pump and so using this
technique Jowita and Jeff were able to
image a large number of blue tones and
what they found was that air puffs
elicited the largest mean calcium
response but only about 20 to 25% of
these long-range inhibitory projections
of the blue tones showed any response
and the response was somewhat variable
in its amplitude when they gave a water
reward
somewhat small it evoked is somewhat
smaller mean response they
a somewhat smaller fraction of blue
tones that respondent and then when they
invoke tones or light the mean response
was even smaller and the fractional of
blue tones that responded were smaller
and interestingly the the blue tones
that responded to one stimuli tended not
to respond to another so they seem to be
largely overlap independent population
of boo tones each of them conveying to
the hippocampus this inhibitory input
from enter I'll cortex in response to
these various stimuli and so finally the
one question was do these inputs have
any behavioral relevance they convey
information about sensory signals in the
environment they convey information
about potential punishments and reward
and so what joy de and Fred Haiti and
the lab did was they asked whether or
not these inputs were necessary for a
simple form of hippocampal dependent
learning and memory contextual fear
conditioning so what they did was they
expressed again this PCM glycine
receptor in inhibitory neurons and
enteral cortex and then they used a
cannula to locally deliver the PCM
login' not to enter Island cortex but to
hippocampus and in this way they
attempted to only silence the
projections from entering the cortex and
not silence the cell bodies or any
projections that these neural inhibitory
neurons might make locally within
anti-rattle cortex and so the protocol
that they used was to on day one they
exposed a mouse into a chamber with
various sensory cues olfactory and
visual and tactile sensory cues this was
a freely moving Mouse they then applied
a tone for 30 seconds and at the end of
the tone they gave the mouse's shock for
two seconds and they left the mouse in
the chamber for another 30 seconds and
on day one on during this training day
the mouse pure behavior was assessed by
the percent of time that the mouse spent
freezing and the mouse basically showed
little freezing
prior to the shock and even after the
shock on day one the freezing wasn't
that great and then to assess memory on
day two they reexpose the mouse to the
same environment in which it had
received the shock and what they found
was that in both the control group and
the group that had been expressing p.m.
both groups were treated with the piece
M log n but the groups both groups
showed a learning clear learning -
depicted by this enhance freezing now
the interesting thing occurred on day
three when they exposed the mouse to a
completely novel context now most mice
including the control mites recognize
this as a neutral context they
distinguish it from the context in which
they were shocked and they show no
freezing however the group in which
these long-range inhibitory projections
have been inactivated during the
training trial during exposure to the
invite training environment in the shock
on day one now showed an inappropriately
high level of freezing so they seemed to
generalize their fear response both to
the context in which they were shocked
but importantly to the context in which
they were not shocked now this wasn't
just a general increase in anxiety
because on day three joy did then
exposed the mice to the tone and the
tone elicits a hippocampal independent
fear response mediated by the amygdala
and nothing was manipulated in the
amygdala in these experiments and both
mice showed a normal freezing response
to the tone so there was no difference
than in the response of the mice of
either group of mice suggesting that
these long-range inhibitory projections
may not be necessary for basic memory
formation but they may be important for
memories ensuring memory specificity so
finally just in the last slide it's a
recent experiments that Felix Leroy has
been doing we've been focusing on ca1
and one question is is I TDP specific
for C a1 or might this be a generalized
learning rule C a2 is a neighboring
region 2 C a1
it also receives direct input from
entering on cortex and input through the
Tri synaptic path from the upstream ca3
region in our lab and others have
recently shown that ca2 is critical for
social memory so Felix began by doing
some experiments pairing stimulation of
the internal cortex and Schaffer
collateral inputs at this 20 millisecond
interval and indeed he found he could
produce a powerful potentiation of the
Schaffer collateral inputs with a small
but significant effect also in this case
on the perform calf inputs this also
involved a powerful suppression of
feed-forward inhibition and it was also
selectively tuned to this 20 millisecond
pairing interval although he saw Felix
or somewhat greater responses at these
other intervals than what we saw in CA 1
now interestingly the although we see
the same type of synaptic learning rule
with the same timing dependence the
nature of the loss of inhibition is
completely different it's a different
class of inter neurons
it's the parvalbumin positive basket
cells that are being decreased in CA 2
and it does not involve in de
cannabinoids
but it involves activation of Delta
opioid receptors so this suggests that
this I TDP may provide this timing
dependence may represent a substantial
actually important mechanism for
regulating the strength of synaptic
transmission although the molecular
mechanism may be tuned differentially to
the local environment the cellular and
the local circuitry that a particular
neuron it happens to be in so then I
think what I've tried to get across
today is that when we want to think
about how the hippocampus or any circuit
works how it forms memories how it
processes information we have to think
both about the long-range excitatory
inputs that are coming into the region
we have to think about how those inputs
or differentially target
to different regions of the dendritic
tree and how that differentially
targeting may be manipulated by the self
to produce interesting computations in
this case we think that ca1 is producing
a computation in collaboration with its
local inhibitory circuitry to
selectively amplify inputs that are
coming in through the Tri synaptic path
based on their relevance on their
salience which is assessed by the timing
delay whether or not they have that
proper 20 millisecond timing delay
indicating that these two pathways may
become bringing in complementary or
converging information onto the onto the
pathway we've also found that these
long-range inhibitory projections
provide a key critical role in enabling
this induction of plasticity and they
gate the information coming in through
the dry synaptic path a single stimulus
to these long-range projections produces
a transient gating tied to that 20
millisecond IPSP repeated activation of
these long-range inputs in the enter a
neural cortex excitatory inputs with the
Schaffer collateral inputs leads to a
long-range gating of the Schaffer
collateral inputs by producing a
long-term suppression of this
feed-forward inhibition from these
inhibitory basket cells so in this way I
think we we can see how circuits can be
designed to act in a very coordinated
fashion and I think in terms of what I
really want to understand in the future
from this is why what is it about this
convergence of this direct information
coming on to the distal dendrites and
this processed information which
probably contains mnemonic information
stored in dentate in CA 3 what is the
nature of that comparison and really
what is it doing toward the circuitry so
finally let me just acknowledge all the
wonderful collaborators I've had joy
about sue just is now an assistant
professor at NYU
Stephanie Chung is
going to medical school bread Hitty is a
neurosurgeon at Penn
Felix Laroy and David Brown are both in
the lab now Josh dun Minh started this
all a number of years ago with David
side and we were grateful we had
wonderful collaboration on the imaging
with attila and jeff Zaremba boris
Immelman gave us an advice and help with
the viruses and some others I thank you
for your attention and for staying awake
for the whole day